manuel afonso bonjour vous êtes la
présidente de la pec montigny le
bretonneux et secrétaire départemental
sur les yvelines déjà question en tant
que mère de famille vous même comment
vous vivez ce confinement mais que vos
enfants à la maison
alors comment on vit le confinement ben
écoutez on a déjà eu à relever le
challenge de l'organisation ce qui n'a
pas été une mince affaire parce qu'entre
l'école à la maison le télétravail
et puis même tout simplement apprendre
le réapprendre le vivre ensemble ça a
été une sacrée aventure là au bout d'une
semaine de confinement on peut vraiment
vraiment dire que ça y est c'est bon on
est sur les rangs bah non
le tout c'est de faire en sorte que que
notre enfant ne soit ne le soit pas trop
trop en difficulté vis-à-vis de ces
exercices
et voilà que ne pas se tirer dans les
pattes ça toute la journée
justement la rectrice à vannes oc une
continuité pédagogique à la peine me
sentais que cette continuité est
présente
ah oui à ça et a aucun doute là dessus
on a vraiment des professeurs ultra
impliqués dans leurs missions au
quotidien on reçoit des plannings avec
des exercices avec avec des consignes
même si j'avoue que certaines méthodes
de travail aurait gagné à être un peu
plus informé auprès des parents mais en
soi on a vraiment une bonne continuité
les professeurs restent disponibles à
moindre question on and on a une adresse
mail on a on a de la possibilité de
skype et aussi des fois il m'est arrivé
de skype et avec la maîtresse de mes
enfants mais toujours va on n'est pas
abandonnée on a eu du mal en tout cas
pour ma part et pour la part des
personnes que j'ai sondé dans les
différentes associations du territoire
des yvelines
on a ressenti au début une forme de
difficultés dans le sens où on n'était
pas assez informés sur les méthodes de
travail qu'il faudrait appliquer
je pense par exemple aux collégiens qui
on a certains établissements qui
applique l'emploi du temps vraiment au
jour le jour
le professeur et d'art son ordinateur au
moment où doit prendre en charge de la
classe on a d'autres établissements où
ça ne fonctionne pas comme ça on a des
difficultés à retrouver les ressources
aussi des fois non par exemple je prends
l'exemple de pronote certains
professeurs vos maîtres dans les devoirs
à faire d'autres dans les ressources ni
à la classe et des fois il ya des petits
loupés en termes de devoirs qu'on
devrait rendre qui sont un peu raté mais
en règle générale
franchement moi je trouve qu'ils ont
fait un travail extraordinaire qui
aurait gagné à avoir un peu plus de
moyens
même si manuel afonso président de la
pub de montigny-le-bretonneux
merci